YouTube is a must use platform for
influencers coaches authors and
freelancers but what about local service
based business owners like plumbers it
can seem like there's a disconnect
between the offline services that
they're offering and this online world
but there has never been a better time
to be building both for your business
and in this episode we bring you one of
the think media success students Roger
Wakefield a texas-based plumber who
shares how he built his youtube media
empire with little to no experience even
if you're not a local based business
owner his experience and tips that he
shares in this podcast will help you
take your youtube game to the next level
marketing show the number one podcast
for growing and scaling your business
with online video
I'm your host Heather Torres and I'm
Shawn Connell and work from think media
and if this is your first time listening
we are fired up you're here this show is
dedicated to helping you learn how to
get your content notice and the latest
money-making strategies that are working
right now online so whether you want to
grow your YouTube channel or you're
ready to maximize video across all of
social media then this podcast is for
you well thank you so much Roger for
being on the podcast today I'm excited
to bring your story and your knowledge
and your expertise to the think
marketing podcast community thank you
for the opportunity I appreciate it
well Roger you know you are a
well-established plumber in Dallas is
that correct Dallas absolutely yes and
you've been doing this for decades is
that correct
I started plumbing 40 years ago 40 years
ago and this has got to be all new to
you right YouTube and understanding
online marketing walk us through your
journey to even getting started on
YouTube what sparked it and why did you
decide that this was the platform that
you wanted to actually start investing
in I got tired of getting ripped off by
OPM marketing other people's money and I
call them other OPM marketing companies
we were trying to make a phone ring at a
plumbing company and we were trying to
market
company's nobody would ever make it
happen the way we thought it should and
we kept trying new companies and we'd
give them you know six months or a year
and we'd move to somebody else and we
delivery started hiring companies that
would make our phone stopped ringing
meaning whatever they were doing the
phones quit ringing and it was killing
us so we're part of an organization
it's called success group International
and they work with plumbers roofers
electricians and HVAC techs I had gone
to the first event with them and I
thought it was really wonderful but I
realized the people that they had
teaching us marketing or just selling us
their marketing plan they're just
selling us SEO and I decided I want to
learn something different I wanted to
learn social media well I used to get up
every morning get on the treadmill and
listen to garyvee different people and
somehow I found a founder magazine
Nathan Chan interviewing Michael
Stelzner and I listened to it he was
talking about social media marketing
world so I came to work the next day I'm
tell my wife I said look I want to go to
this I want to do this and we looked at
our budget and we said look it's really
tight but you know what if you think
that's what it's gonna take
go ahead so I showed up in San Diego it
was two weeks before the event so I paid
full price for a ticket it was two weeks
before so I got there got a flat booked
I'm a hotel booked I showed up an hour
early because that's just me I'm an
early riser I walked into the Convention
Center the doors were open so I went
down to the registration said look can I
go ahead and register I'm here young
lady registered me and she looks down
another list and says okay you're a
plumber I'm gonna find some plumbers for
you to hang out with and she looks and
she said okay there's no plumbers here
who else would you hang out with and I
explained residential service people I
said you know electricians HVAC techs
roofers landscapers and window cleaners
anything like that and she looks at in
the list and she looks up at me almost
brokenhearted and she says Roger I'm
sorry there's nobody here like you and I
just started smiling from ear to ear and
I thought oh my gosh this is crazy
and she looked at me and she says I
don't know who you're gonna hang out
with I said don't worry about me I'm
gonna be good the second day that I was
there I was walking to a different
session and I saw the placard set up
that talked about derral eves
and it was using video to get in front
of your custom or something like that
and it was so funny and I'll tell you
how little I knew about social media
when I walked in and sat down then I'm
one of these front row guys I'm a DV so
you know people moving around I lose
focus and I'm on the front row and I'm
watching him and he said YouTube is the
second largest search engine in the
world and I almost got up and walked out
because I thought this guy has no idea
what he's talking about YouTube is just
a storage place for videos and I just I
did it I just i sat there and I kept
listening and he started talking about
the squatty potty and everything he had
done and it blew my mind and I knew
right then that I was gonna start doing
YouTube and we released our first real
video a month later and we've done three
a week every week since then
that's amazing you've now grown this
YouTube channel too right now it's at
27,000 subscribers that are interested
in plumbing and all things to do with
you know the things that you are talking
about that is amazing and now that
you've been doing this Roger for some
time now what do you think the benefits
of having you know marketing your
business on YouTube what is that done to
your overall business and your overall
brand even personally and for the
business that you're running the first
thing that it did is we quit spending
money on Google
meaning we used to buy Google AdWords
now like you said earlier I'm in Dallas
my competition they do about fifty five
sixty five million dollars a year as a
plumbing company we're a million dollar
a year company nothing big small
boutique perfect we want to do things
right all the time but I can't compete
with those Google ad dollars like that
literally for pay-per-click plumbing
here in Dallas can get upwards of 150
dollars a click now that's not a call
that's not a customer that's just
somebody clicking on your video I mean
on your ad we're not doing that anymore
we literally started making YouTube
content and I love it because a lot of
you
people tell me where you can't brand
YouTube locally and I'm like okay you
keep thinking that I love it because we
are yeah we're making it work and I
cannot tell you how many calls we get a
day say hey look we saw Roger on YouTube
and we've got a question and most of the
time the calls are from around here but
I mean we've had calls we had to call a
funny call one afternoon a lady from
South Carolina calls and says hey my
water heaters making noises I need to
talk to Roger right now because it's
gonna blow up and you know they laugh
around here they're like hey look it's
not gonna blow up Rogers not in but let
me get you with another plumber so it's
crazy but it has worked yeah it seems as
I know you know building a local
business through the ability to build
know like and trust with your audience
you're on camera they're seeing you they
know you and when you invite a plumber
in to your home or anyone that's working
in your home you don't really
necessarily know who they are before
they get there and this is helping you
you and your whole entire team to be
pre-qualified I'm sure to allow people
to go hey I know Roger and they know the
Corky things about you and you become
the Roger who lives next door right you
become the plumber they recommend
because they have on their own built
know like and trust with you and we
change that just a little bit we go with
know love trust and connect because now
they're connected that we they invite me
into their house they invite me into
their car to listen to me driving home
they invite me on a workout with them if
they're listening to the audio and
that's what I used to do on the
treadmill I set the iPad up but I'm
listening I may be watching I may not
but I'm listening and that's what I
wanted to do I wanted to be able to talk
to people about plumbing problems or how
to become a problem plumber or how to
fix the problems of starting your own
company or how to grow it so it's really
been great that's amazing and I just I
love the the community I I was in I love
going in and watching the videos that of
the people that were interviewing and
the people like you who are speaking at
Grows video live this year I want to see
what you're doing and the
unity you're building around plumbing
guys this is what we mean when we say
that video that YouTube specifically
could blow up your brand the reason for
that is because you're creating people
to have like-minded interests that are
that want to know and that have a
problem you become their problem solver
and I've been able to sink Roger the
community that you guys are creating
around plumbing it's funny you put it
that way because I mean you know who
Michael Stelzner is I got a phone call a
couple of weeks ago and actually it
started as a LinkedIn connection but
Bruce Irvin called and said I want to
put you on my podcast and I said why
would you want me on your podcast he
said what's funny I was talking or
interviewing Michael Stelzner and
Michael Stelzner he have a question
about using YouTube for local branding
and Michael Stelzner started laughs I
said look you I'll talk about YouTube
and local branding you need to interview
Rodger Wakefield he's killing it and
it's just kind of crazy the way your
writing gets out there and people see
what you're doing in celebration of the
launch of this brand new podcast we're
giving away two tickets to our annual
conference grow with video live a
fifteen hundred dollar value all you
have to do to enter is make sure you
subscribe leave us a review on Apple
podcast and then take a screenshot of
your review and go to think marketing
show.com for the rest of the details
yeah you become not only just Authority
in the industry that you're in but now
you've grown to a wider audience and
being able to be the person that can
help other business owners in the trades
that you're in so that's what I want to
get into next I love to give tangible
tips to our audience and so Roger if
you're speaking to you know the guy
who's an electrician or someone who is a
you said working on air conditioners or
a painter or a carpenter someone that's
in those trade industries let's give
them three practical things that they
can do to grow their business using
YouTube and tip number one you said was
actually get started go ahead and tell
me about that well think about what I
told you about me going to social media
marketing world we literally it when I
was there an 18 it
is Wednesday Thursday and Friday now I
had to leave before the keynote on
Friday because I had a radio show in
Dallas Saturday morning on the way home
that night on the plane I am going
through my notes trying to come up with
a plan what do I want to do after the
radio show the next day I came back to
the office going through my notes again
my wife and I got a Sunday morning went
to church took her home dropped her off
came back to the office going through my
notes again and when my wife and my
stepson will he's my CMO my digital
overlord all kinds of crazy titles but
when they came in Monday morning I said
guys look we're changing things and
we're changing it right now and I think
that's the key thing that people need to
understand get started now and if I
would have walked in the office Monday
morning and let the plumbing company
take over and plumbing happens every day
and if I would have walked in and not
got started I would not be doing what
I'm doing now I would still be plumbing
and you know maybe this week I'm saying
oh gosh you know what social media
marketing world's going on I'll go learn
something again maybe I'll learn
something better it's not what we learn
but it's what we do with it and just
getting started and your if you get
started now you're gonna be ahead of 95%
of the country and that's gonna help you
in the long run
yeah and it's just the getting started
part it's getting over who you know I'm
not a plumber I mean I am a plumber I'm
not a youtuber so let's talk about
number two which is learn the tools the
thing that I realized coming home from
social media marketing world was I just
found a whole bunch of new tools
meaning I found YouTube I found video I
found social media I met people from
across the country that were great
resources that I could talk to that I
could reach out to that I could learn
from that first social media marketing
world asset in Shawn's class asset and
Pete Vargas's and everybody had
something different but it was
all look there's a right way to reach
out and engage your community grow a
community and be part of the community
and what I realized is it's just like a
plumbing tool if a new tool comes out
and I don't learn how to use it it's
never going to help me
but YouTube these cameras these
microphones it started with my phone and
and then a cheap computer camera got a
Logitech and it's grown from that I'm
looking at a Sony and a Canon right now
but that's not what I started with but
if I would have waited until I could
afford all the equipment that I wanted
to use I'd never get started I increase
I improve one percent at a time every
video we try to do one thing better
let's focus on this let's focus on this
let's do one thing better the tools that
are in front of us if we learn to use
them the right way we can do anything we
want to do and that's what I walked away
with a social media marketing rose look
I've got a whole bunch of new tools do I
go home and put them on a shelf or do I
pull them out and learn how to use them
very very well yeah and it's so critical
that you know we we aren't taken back by
the tech the tech really is something
that holds so many business owners back
and I mean you went to school you went
you you had to learn the trade you did
an apprenticeship you have to still be
in this phase of just learning you know
the first time you did a video Roger I'm
sure Polly was not your your best video
is that correct and I'll leave it up
there I remember Sean talking one time
about some of his first videos and and
it's funny because we just had this
conversation yesterday we'll walked in
the office he said like I've come back
through our channel there's a lot of
videos that still don't have but you
know 2530 views they're really not very
good do we want to go ahead and delete
them and I'm like no and he's like why
so you know what cuz I tell people all
the time like oh look when I started I
was horrible but you know what at least
I was trying at least I was getting up
and doing it and you know what when
people said hey your your lighting is no
good it's like okay how do I make it
better what do I do
or I'd look it up
it is what it is people are gonna hate
you people are gonna love you I get
comments all the time telling me you
know I want to become a plumber now I
watched your videos I don't want to go
to college I don't I didn't know what
else to do but I love what you're
talking about and whether they are just
the passion that they say or the fact
that I really love what I do I'm using a
whole new tool talking to a whole new
group of people and to me that's what
it's all about yeah it's amazing what
these tools can - can gift us see like
you said the idea to be able to talk to
the other person on camera but I know
that that is actually something that
holds people back you know when you
click that record button when you turn
it on when you set up your microphone
you get ready for me when I do my hair
my makeup and and all those things it
can feel so intimidating because you
start thinking about yourself and like
am I gonna sound good is this about me
but tip number three is to always think
about the person on the other side of
the camera how has that helped you in
developing out your YouTube strategy the
thing is I never think about me it's in
I mean look I don't have much hair to
fix so I really don't have to worry
about that my makeup is perfect
every day my thing is I understand that
I'm talking to somebody you know getting
to talk to you earlier watching you do
an interview earlier I know your story
from setting in Sean sessions so I feel
like I know you and when I look at this
camera that that's who I'm talking to
when I'm making a video talking about
plumbing at someone's house or how to
get into the trade or something I'm
literally thinking about that person
sitting on the other side of the camera
watching me that wants to know what do I
have to do to become a plumber or what
do I have to do if my water heater is
making noise and I think that if
everybody who makes a video number one
look at that lens look at that camera
right in the eye and connect with it
because there is somebody on the other
side looking you right in your eyes that
wants to learn whatever is you're
talking about and if we always think
about the person on the other side
we're gonna connect with somebody and it
does it makes such a big difference yeah
I've noticed that even in what we're
doing here at think media and and I
think marketing is the idea that I want
to create content for you you know if
you're listening to this podcast right
now I know so many things about you just
because of the type of content that we
are creating here what we're niching
down into and so our I love that you
said that it's not about you it's about
the person on the other side and the
connection that you can have with them I
am so excited Roger for you to be one of
the speakers this year at grow with
video live we have this is the number
one video marketing conference here in
the US and we want to bring people just
like Roger to you here at the think
marketing podcast but at our live event
that's happening in September here in
Las Vegas and Roger I know you're going
to be sharing some amazing tips on how
you've used YouTube to grow your local
business and you're gonna be a resource
there to be able to connect with other
people just like when you were at social
media marketing world and they said
there's no one here for you we're making
sure that here at grow us video live
there's someone for you so Roger what
are you excited about this year for
growth video live Heather the neat thing
to me is one of the things that I teach
about isn't that working and my wife and
I are into networking that's how she's
growing her business that's how I
started grow in the plumbing company but
I remember when she first told me to go
networking I thought you know I'm a
plumber plumbers don't network but I do
I get out and I network and it's funny
because the first time we walked into an
event together she took me dragging and
screaming but what I did is I told her
look you go your way I'm gonna go mine
we're not here to hang out together
we'll see how this works at the end of
the night she came up to me and she says
oh my god Roger every time I looked up
you've got a crowd around you you've got
your arms going and you're talking and
you're all this she said what what were
you doing I said well people had
plumbing problems they asked me
questions I just tell them what's going
wrong what's happening with it
and that's what I think a lot of people
need to learn is learn to network learn
to build that relationship because
whether you're in a room with somebody
Heather or
you're in social media you're building a
relationship and think about it if
somebody walks up to you at an event
anywhere and just this hey look I've got
it I've got something I'm selling I want
to sell it to you now sign the paper
here let me get your address and all
this you're like you know what back up
but people try to do that on social
media all the time learn to build the
relationship first and if you build that
relationship you can become the person
that people know love trust and connect
with and that's huge that's amazing
Roger I am really really excited for the
think media community to get to see you
in person on stage at grow this video
live and thank you so much for your time
today and I can't wait to see you in
September
thank you this has been wonderful and
I've really been looking forward to this
because Bing and Sean sessions before
I've heard your story and I love what
you're doing and I tell people all the
time look this lady's doing phenomenal
things you can do it too because we've
all got a story we've all got a passion
and we all I think deep inside want to
reach out and help other people so thank
you for this I do I love what you're
doing well that was actually a really
great interview with Roger I totally
agree man I'm so inspired by Roger and
what I love is the fact that he just
took massive action you know it could be
scary especially when video was not your
main thing YouTube social media is new
to you but as a business owner he
realized how important and powerful was
and he's just experienced massive
momentum because he pressed record yeah
and I love that Roger is gonna be
speaking this year at groweth video live
and if you would like to get your
tickets to grow this video live and see
some of the amazing deals we have right
now you can go to grow with video
live.com and you can see all of the
speakers that will be here this year but
before we go we want you to take out a
notebook right now you just watch that
whole interview with Roger and I want to
know what is one action that you're
going to take what's something you're
gonna do to move your business forward
yes and we also want to give a shout out
to the review of the week and here's
what it says my twin brother and I have
learned so much from Sean's YouTube
content in such little
compared to what a traditional college
course would teach the great thing is
with us having business management
degrees we have a good understanding of
core business principles but Sean's
content has helped us easily identify
how that translates to online video it's
always about influence income and impact
thank you so much for leaving that
review and we didn't leave a name there
so actually if you haven't rated and
reviewed this podcast definitely do that
let us know your name so we can shout
you out and maybe feature you in one of
these weekly comment audience community
shout outs and if you didn't know we're
actually giving away two tickets to grow
a video live if you rate and review the
podcast while we're just launching the
think marketing show we're in the early
episodes still and we're so pumped that
you've been a part of this journey with
us so if you go to think marketing show
com you can get details about how to go
through a few simple steps to just rate
review the podcast and then you'll be
entered to win two tickets to hear from
Roger to hear from Heather tourists and
all of our other great speakers yeah and
if you want to be a part of the think
marketing community here you can
subscribe wherever you're listening or
if you're on youtube you can subscribe
right there and leave us a comment rate
us and review us like Sean just said but
if you're listening and watching on
youtube we would love to connect with
you in the comments below thanks for
listening to this episode and we'll see
you in the next one